hi my name is Pete Davidson thank you so
much for making a comment publicly that
I didn't adopt
Ed do your research
for people Pete Davidson goes off on
Peta for slamming his decision to buy a
hypoallergenic dog from a pet store
instead of adopting one what kind of
puppy did we get what's the name I'm
allergic to dogs uh so it's hard for me
to find a dog I'm not allergic to so I
found a Cavapoo on Monday the Saturday
Night Live Alum left a heated voicemail
for PETA an animal rights organization
who had previously given a statement to
TMZ about Pete's choice to buy a puppy
at a New York City pet store I just want
to
[Music]
and those type of dogs and my mom's dog
who's two years old died a week prior
and were all so sad so I had to get a
specific dog so why don't you do
research
create news stories for people because
you're a boring tired
you and suck my Pete previously shared
the news of their family dog's death
last month with an emotional message
posted to his pal Dave Cyrus's Instagram
account because Pete doesn't use social
media he explained yesterday we lost a
key member of the Davidson family Henry
was only two years old but unfortunately
got very sick very fast the comedian
writes they got Henry at the beginning
of the pandemic and he saved their lives
not sure I'd even be around without him
he was the happiest and sweetest dog
ever now in the wake of Pete's rant the
animal rights organization issued a
statement to E.T saying their hearts go
out to Pete and his family for the loss
of their beloved pup we know Pete cares
about animals and was trying to do a
nice thing for his family but he has
millions of impressionable fans and his
choices matter Peta adds that they hope
next time he makes the compassionate
choice to add opt not buy
ET was with Pete on Monday night where
he revealed the new puppy's name was
inspired by a comedy Legend his name is
Rodney Dangerfield and I bought him a
little red tie and we're going to teach
him how to go like this no yeah so he
could tell jokes didn't go like that
yeah like no respect hey yeah well
that's the story of my life no respect
it actually really looks like Rodney
Dangerfield and it's going to get a lot
of perspective yeah and he's gonna get
mad yeah yeah and on Tuesday following
all the back and forth Pete issued an
apology to Peta saying in a statement to
TMZ that by buying the new dog he was
just trying to cheer up his family but
when Peta made a public example of him
it made The Grieving situation worse I
shouldn't have said what I said but I am
not sorry for standing up for myself and
my family
[Music]